[Music]
the future of Marvel seems to be pretty
female and it's a great time to be a
woman and I feel like we're seeing so
many powerful female ensembles on screen
oh yeah congrats on annihilation thank
you so much Panther is killing it I mean
are we gonna see that more in the Marvel
Universe I heard you were pushing for an
all-female Marvel movie I think what
we're seeing regardless of Lady
liberators are an eighth worst movie or
you know a female ensemble Marvel movie
is that in phase four women rule supreme
and we're seeing a black widow movie in
the works which I hear about and is so
exciting and Captain Marvel with brie
Larson and Wanda wise so we are seeing
that women are at the forefront of these
stories and of course with black panther
that you know those incredible warrior
women in that film and then with your
character in Thor what aspects and what
backstory do you hope to explore in
future Marvel films it depends on which
iteration of Valkyrie you see in the
comics there's all sorts of interesting
stuff I mean I think it'd be fun to see
her on earth I think it would be fun to
see her in more unexpected team-ups
because she has such a sort of brash
particular personality right so it would
be funny to see her in the MTE
empty you've seen who she gets along
with who she maybe doesn't get along
with I think that the possibilities are
wide open which MCU female character
would you like to team up with if you
had to pick I mean quays pretty cool you
know I I mean you know Valkyrie would
really just like that I bow down to her
the bright Murray would just be like yes
my long-lost is like just because she's
like you know leader of the the Valkyrie
of Wakanda so that would be exciting
obviously it'd be so cool to team up
with Black Widow is Scarlett your hands
in the sort of og superheroes you know
both of those or the three of us could
just go for lunch right and just let you
live our best life yeah
[Music]